what you're looking at the very latest
pictures more areas around the capital
kiev coming under attack on day two of
russia's full-scale attack on ukraine
explosions and gunfire being reported in
the northern district is called obalon
it is about 15
kilometers from the city center
pedestrians reportedly running for
safety
to the sound of small arms fire larger
blasts could be heard around the city
center the ukraine defense ministry has
urged citizens to stay at home we will
stay with those pictures and re-rack
them for you as you try to get a sense
of what's going on there so it's nine
hours gmt that's
11 a.m local time andrew simmons is our
correspondent there andrew dramatic
events unfolding by the minute now where
you are and that column of tanks we
think making its way down from the
border with belarus
yes it's how much of the column of tanks
is on the move is unclear because uh
ukrainian forces blew up a bridge uh
which was approaching obalon that bridge
is in is completely destroyed this is
impossible for the column to advance uh
beyond that bridge uh we're not sure of
the amount of of fire power that's
crossed it uh but we do know that there
has been fierce fighting between
ukrainian forces uh and and the than
this column um we're not sure whether
they have detachments of of of anti-tank
missile troops there or not we're not
clear on it but there's been a large uh
number of explosions we've heard from
here it's around about 15 kilometers
probably between 10 and 15 kilometers
in this direction which is the northwest
and and we're hearing a number of things
we're hearing that civilians were
running for their lives
it is a residential district
high-rise apartments
there and we are also hearing from the
ministry of defense
which says has been calling on people to
stay indoors in this residential area
even though quite often that the air
raid sirens are sounding but there's
been it's been reasonably quiet for the
past 40 minutes um they are being asked
to throw molotov cocktails if they can
somehow make such things with
clear bottles and and petrol at any
russian troops they can see which is an
extraordinary request from the ministry
of defense but basically that is the
frame of mind most people are in right
now if you want to do something you've
got to try to resist
violently
the russian aggression now we're also
hearing that the numbers the amounts of
of ammunition being passed on to
civilians is getting extraordinary
something like 10 000 ak-47s people you
see we've seen people in the streets
with rucksacks with ak-47s just shoved
in so we have a situation now
where we do have a close contact now
between ukrainian forces and russian
forces within
well within shouting distance no that's
an exaggeration but certainly within 10
kilometers of the city on the northwest
entrance and a crimean um
a russian um column from crimea uh is
approaching uh on on another level
altogether on a different from a
different direction but effectively
what's trying what they're trying to do
is three separate armored columns with
all the backup needed and of course air
cover as well and all the missiles being
being thrown into the equation uh are
going to are trying to do a triangular
action uh on the city to basically seal
it off
they were not sure exactly obviously
what tactics are going on in certain
areas but the ministry of defense is
also warning about russian undercover
saboteurs
the city itself there have been shooting
incidents
you hear hear of them all the time um
sort of unprovoked sometimes but
certainly there is a lot going on
and a lot of tension
we'll get to what happened overnight in
kiev in a minute or two if we may andrew
but just to go back to this or to stay
with the discussion on this column of
tanks that you're reporting for us here
this hour um it's a sizable distance
from kiev to the border with belarus
if this long convoy of tanks and we're
also seeing on the footage that we're
playing in from this end i know you guys
can't see it where you are but we're
playing in user generated content and
also news agency footage of what looks
like armored personnel carriers or troop
movement lorries and trucks on the roads
in that area if that column of tanks got
from bella belarus to 10k
from kiev
overnight
they did it quite quickly and they
didn't encounter much resistance because
they're there they've made it they're on
the outskirts of kiev well
you're asking the right person to
estimate timings on that because as a
team we went to beyonce
which is a town where they did meet some
resistance and further on to send kiefka
now that is
the furthest crossing point you can find
on the belarus um ukraine border there
actually is a three-way border because
it's the border with russia as well now
we visited there on the wednesday and we
saw
the sort of defenses that border had got
they were minimal
and the border guards
who are very you know it's possible
they're not alive anymore the border
guards we spoke to uh said yes it's
going to be tough
we won't be able to resist it but we
better call in forces that will
and um that that border
if you if we drove it there and it was
about three hours
yeah it was three hours and um
coming back we stopped a few times it
was about three and a half now bear in
mind this that when the onslaught was
launched uh on on the wednesday
morning in the early hours uh sorry the
thursday morning in the early hours
there was
a movement
all around it wasn't just
air raids missile launches it was a
movement of armory uh from all borders
so if you actually work that out it's
taken
you know a day a day and a night for
that column to get on the outskirts of
of this city it's met resistance it's a
long column it's met a lot of resistance
by air
and on the ground as well but it's
armory and it's got air cover so
it doesn't take a lot to really work out
with mathematics that that column is
on the outskirts of the city in what
state it's in we're not sure
as you're talking to us andrew we have
access to uh some more live pictures of
what looks like a a downed uh military
aircraft someplace close to where you're
reporting from it looks like it either
came down with a fireball or it started
a fireball as it landed just to
fill in the the back story to this we've
sort of we flick a switch and we tap
into for the sake of our viewers
watching this we tap into a feat of
pictures we have no control over what
the camera crew there on the ground in
kiev are filming but they've chosen to
rest that shot on a completely and
utterly destroyed building to the right
of that there is the remnants of what is
clearly an aircraft we saw the remnants
of
the aircraft fuselage which is almost
completely destroyed a couple of
aircraft engines uh that's just one
aspect andrew of what's been going on
overnight just just walk us through
how much fire how much of the distant
crump of conflict could you hear there
in kiev in the hours of darkness
well well the that that's a wreckage
you're looking at i can tell you i can
confirm because there's only one plane
that's been shot down in the past uh six
hours it was a a a
a fighter bomber uh blown out by
ukrainian air defenses and sadly it
crashed into the building and you're
probably seeing the wreckage of that
building
it hit that civilian area and burst into
flames naturally and we don't know the
the casualties there that we know that
there is at least one person dead uh
that is
what happens in war not only was that
plane blown out of the sky but the
ukrainians ministry of defense is saying
that two cruise missiles were shot uh
were shot down uh by well they would
have exploded obviously so they they
would have reached the ground they would
have hit the ground in flames the
remnants of them
they were hit overnight as well
so the ukrainian air defenses are
working they may not be intensive but
they were working overnight you could
hear the outgoing
a lot during the night and the thump of
distant artillery the crashes
of missiles hitting military targets on
the outskirts of the city but what we're
finding now as as all the armory gets
closer is they're getting into civilian
areas and the civilian casualty rate is
going to increase there's no doubt about
it and i'm only talking about the
capital here remember just about every
big city in ukraine is under attack
kharkiv was having a terrible time of it
all the way through thursday people in a
desperate state and people in queues
to donate blood at medical points